so we're here this is the ultimate fact
the access is the ultimate thing right
the explosion of messaging apps like
that messages snapchat all that stuff
how can you leverage that without
sacrificing your sanity and all your
time do you even think about that so
there's a guy right now he's got he
started a I don't see anybody doing
anything like this at all he started
rather than doing a Facebook group he
says I'm gonna do a facebook chat now
it's annoying because I'm always getting
notifications popping up but I see let's
stop there yeah that's going to play
itself out is that you're going to play
yourself out for you because the first
word out of your mouth is it's annoying
so you're valuing it as a marketer
because you're seeing it a lot but
seeing it and consuming it seeing it
consuming it and acting on it are two
very different things
so let me set it up go ahead I get
energized by my students contacting me
hmm and just like you get in a giant
room telling you man I did I did what
you said it it worked I mean the amount
of time I mean you guys remember I for a
few minutes tested each at like like a
little fake little app like god I get
energized yeah but I cannot scale that
I've got thirty students now right but
when I have 300 there's no way that I
can make that happen unless I have them
pay for that access right so that's one
Avenue but is there a you're looking for
the scalable version we're going to sell
your message app that can answer the
questions for $19.99 no no okay I'm
looking to charge I'm looking to charge
myself up but I don't know how to do and
messaging is an amazing way to give them
your cell number
I just think that text messaging is so
huge but I don't see anybody effectively
scaling it okay I got it
I got to think about this a little bit
more let's stay on it for a minute
either you don't you're not telling me
the full story and it's not just about
getting charged up which is what I think
or you are a person that needs to see
somebody else do something to give you
belief in it both are bad so which one
is it there's probably a little bit of
truth in the second one good right good
that's fine and there's nothing wrong
with fast following yes not as good as
being the first one but it's super fine
and if you're better at it and see me
better so go ahead but I truly I feel
like my purpose yes outside of being a
father yes is for not not necessarily
fulfilled but I feel like I'm getting
closer to realizing my purpose which is
to help people get unstuck from stupid
things that prevent them from doing so
let me ask you a question if that's your
purpose my friend why don't you do it
for free
like I do it since it's my purpose to
purpose
to purpose if it's free you'll have more
people now show me in your actions that
it's actually your purpose yeah cuz it's
the truth
your purpose doesn't come with an
asterisk at a CH for $4.99 a month not
your purpose your business does yeah
please don't [ __ ] me the difference
between your business and your purpose
you much like a charge for what we're
doing here right now a lot more than the
[ __ ] three [ __ ] it was at three four
yeah
is it your purpose because if it is do
it for free and give everybody your
[ __ ] cell phone number that's the
realest [ __ ] man yeah you know what I
mean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]